It's so crazy when they introduce animals
to an island and it winds up fucking
everything up like the Galapagos islands,
you know,
and I'm sure you're familiar with the,
um, Judas, Judas goats, Judas goats.
Are those the ones in the Galapagos?
Do you know how they do that?
I don't advocate goats.
It's really interesting. Not
from the helicopters. Yeah.
Well this is how they do it. They cast
goats like to hang out together. Right.
But sometimes hard to locate them.
So they put a radio collar on one goat.
They castrate it and then they let it
loose and they gunned down all the goats
around it and let that go. Go
find the rest of the goats. No.
And he goes and finds the rest of it goes.
Then they gunned down those goats
because they have the radio collar. Yeah.
So these, what does this Jamie picture
of a Judas Code? I guess he's just,
hey, maybe there's a couple
other pictures. How sad is that?
Single goat's life. He's like new
friends. What the fuck? Yeah. Helicopters.
So I'm actually heading there on
a Monday. They call it goes. Yeah.
They make you take your shoes off,
right.
And scrubbed to make sure that you don't
have weird seeds and the bottom of your
shoe. I have to stop eating seeds,
quarantine for 48 hours when we arrived.
I'm eating seeds. So you don't
shut it out. Exactly. Yup.
Quarantine for 48 hours. Yup. Wow. Why,
why is there so much concern
about this one area? Uh,
I mean it's the dawn of evolution.
You know,
it's where Darwin came up with a theory
of evolution and due to the finches,
it's, it has been destroyed in
some aspects and it's been a,
the habitat has been
fixed in a lot of places.
There's been great conservation efforts
and personally I love what they're doing
because they're trying to
keep it pristine. You know,
I think it's fantastic
that there's a quarantine.
I think it's great that I'm not supposed
to eat seeds for two weeks before going
there. Um, and it's, it's to
keep it as perfect as it is now.
The island that I'm going to with,
with my small team has like
nobody ever stepped foot on it.
It's an active volcano erupts every year.
It's this crazy harsh environment.
We have to have a new pair of boots every
day cause the melts melts and shreds
your boots. Just walking on it. It's
been described as hell on earth.
So I'm stoked.
Wow.
And what kind of protective gear do
you have to wear other than your boots?
Just long sleeved clothing.
I mean, is it yet,
it's so the guy was telling me it's
like 45 degrees Celsius. So that's,
it's well over a hundred. Um,
and yeah, and that's, you know,
we've got to be careful about
water and hiking and there's just,
there's a lot of elements. But that's
the thing is I'm looking for an animal.
Nobody's seen oh very long amount of time.
So you've got to go to these places.
Nobody's going. Wow, that's
incredible. You know, it's,
it's interesting the idea of
invasive species too, right?
Because like Hawaii's a good example.
Hawaii,
there's been talk of getting rid of
pigs. Yup. And a lot of the natives,
they're like, well, slow down.
Because if they're w we hunt
them, we eat them. Right.
If they're invasive than what
are we, right. Totally is.
The pigs were here right around the same
time that people were there and they've,
we've existed together. They need
each other and its culture. You know,
at that point it's,
it's Polynesian culture to eat a
fire roasted pig and hunt your pig.
And so it's a delicate balance.
Like Hawaii is a perfect,
there's Mongie so we're introduced
that destroyed the birds. And uh,
there's turtles,
there's frogs,
there's all kinds of things
that have been brought in there.
But none of those are culturally
significant. Whereas the pig is,
you're saying is a huge cultural
significance. So where is the balance?
Well one of the best examples
of that would be like Lanai.
Cause Lanai has this insane population
have access to here and we go and bow
hunt them there every year.
They're delicious and they're plentiful.
And it's one of the most really ethical
hunts cause you have to hunt them, right?
I mean they are so overpopulated as 20,000
of them on an island with 3000 people.
Yep. And uh, have you ever been till the
night? I have. Yeah, I was diving there,
spear fishing there. Do you see all
the stacks everywhere. Everyone ran us.
It is great. And they're so
beautiful with their spots and yeah,
they're amazing Adam. And
you know, I'm all for it.
Like hunting as a tool for
conservation. Absolutely. Yeah.
But it's just bizarre that they did that.
They did decide to let dear loose on
an island with nothing to eat the deer,
but people. Right. And
then when this was done,
it was like King Kamehameha with just,
what year was that?
I couldn't say a long time ago. Yeah,
long time ago. So back then they, I mean,
I don't even know if they had guns.
I mean,
how were they hunting these things
back then? Bose and spirits. Right.
And they brought him over from Asia,
right? Yup, Yup. They're from Asia.
Same thing with New Zealand, right?
There's an axis steer, there's goats,
there's all kinds of things
are not access, but red deer,
down there and same thing.
They're all brought in for sport.
Yeah. New Zealand's a weird one. Right?
So as Australia, they brought a lot
of stuff over there from, from Europe,
but New Zealand specifically,
they were trying to make it
like a hunter's paradise. Right.
And I think it is right. Tell me if
I'm wrong. No, it is, but it's a,
it's a weird one because it's mostly
high fence. You're going to love this.
So under my extinct animal thing,
they've took moose in the New Zealand.
They took like 10 of them.
Small population believe
that they've been hunted out.
You know, they shot the last one,
blah, blah, blah blah. There's one guy,
crazy looking dude, long hair,
long beard, like nuts looking guy.
And he's been on the hunt, not hunt, hunt,
but like trying to prove that the
New Zealand Moose is still there.
He's found antler sheds,
he's found betting sites.
Some guy even got a picture of one
standing on a rock and you know,
Moose to me it's 100% and Moose.
And so they're in theory somewhere
down in the South Island.
There's one or two or three of these
super elusive Mousse that have been in New
Zealand for like 50 years. Whoa. Wow.
Well New Zealand is so fucking
rugged. Yeah, there's a,
a friend of mine has been there. My
friend Adam Green tree, he's been there,
he lives in Australia and he goes there
to hunt tar and you know they live in
the on the steep steep,
it's crankiest shale where the rock's
real slippery and it's just like cold as
shit. Really high altitude. And you've
seen them before, right? Yeah. Yeah.
I had it look like a science fiction
animal there as, as me and my friend,
me and the guys I work with like
to say stranger than fiction.
You look at it and you're like,
that's not a real creature.
Like some kid drew that.
Yeah.
Like a big old shaggy weird looking
thing where they think they are in New
Zealand.
Yeah.
Did you see that picture of the one
on the rock sticking out right there?
Yeah, that's the last one that
was taped. Last picture taken.
There's a recent one though.
There's one from like two or three
years ago and I looked at it, I'm like,
that's a moose. Like, I don't know who's
saying it's not, but it's a mousse. Wow.
Yeah. From 1952 yeah.
That's 100% a moose. Right.
Again,
how weird is it that there's animals
that you know are there and then there's
animals?
Like we must find that.
So they spend incredible amounts of time
and all of these resources. Is that it?
That's the one, yeah. That's 100% of
the fricking moves. No doubt about it.
That's what I'm saying.
Goddammit people. Yeah.
That doesn't even make sense that
anybody would argue that. Right.
That's a pretty clear picture.
But that's not proof cause they need
genetic material. They need for,
they need something. What do
they think that is? A cloud.
Exactly. Oh, rubber Moose.
That someone's stuck their it to goof
on people are they like arguing that
somebody could have computer generated it
to fool people and all those, you know,
all those. And I appreciate
it. Right. As a scientist,
I appreciate the fact that
you have to have proof. Right.
But it does get to the point
of ridiculousness. Yeah.
Well it's certainly possible. It's
certainly possible that they've, I mean,
especially when you're looking at
that insanely dense terrain right.